no doubt this is a given test
[Music]
thank you very much for starters I
would like to excuse the absence of the
President of the European Commission
indeed as you know at the start of the
meeting she was informed is a
person who is considered a  closed
this contact has been tested positively to
make the necessary of mousse and louis
d'or three stories dreams and photo
cross des must be fully implemented
crowd stop index also creation of
international credible and tifa de uk
on the one hand oil and we will work  is all
levels and fall outcomes in claudine
debt
finally odile you understood it
we had the opportunity today not
only wolves to listen
carefully and women you have some future
leadership or take two big ben is in
germany is a  particle in oignies
as a title of level playing field
fisheries and governance to congratulate them
that the budget is only a small thing
with us if you tube [ __ ] you without
you expect induce  d enders and louis ii this
for other massifs it's been ten years
since we imagined routes with 16.3
markets yes our rates and our pros
cups troubles in fact she woods
twist and takes off shores of heaven
jobs have all failed to  cannes sound by
the light of the sun tv where there is one at
8% united ain't where they trample itrust
we wear
archives born from michel barnier a whole
sign to the negotiations
and we call we say ok to make the
necessary mousse
s  yes of historical order of agreements
and fotopulos of must be fully
implements it crowd stop index also
attraction at the end credibility voice of
uk a parallel the wac is all levels
and fall out boys including is profaned
odile you understood it before had
the  opportunity today not only
doubts listened carefully to the
briefing presented by our
chief negotiator michel barnier in front of an opportunity
to express european unity within the
framework of this negotiation process
we wish  be mobilized to
allow a hacker to be possible with
the united kingdom and at the same time
we continue to defend the principles
which are important to us the level
penfield the question of the governance
of the agreement but also the question
of fishing are  obviously topics
for which from the start we have
expressed a certain number of principles
and set of commitments which we
believe to be important we are ready to
continue the negotiations and we have
had the opportunity to express an
extremely calm European position extremely
calm and  in the case of which
we hope it will be possible to
make progress in order to be able to bring
clarity to the tilles will be possible but
it is more vague michel barnier thank you and
good day to each and every one of
you a first word will be for
thank president charles michel for
associating me with this press point obviously
ursula von der leyen cannot be there
as she should  has
for the reasons that you know
she asked me personally to
represent her
and I can say is that she follows
with great permanent attention with her
team another team which is also
hers this negotiation as she
did not  later than last night in
dialogue with president charles
michel and boris johnson and she will
continue her contacts with the
british prime minister
obviously as often as necessary
we ar absolute and determine twitch verdi
le or les uk ou le mans oil all to
all  world on all subjects and at the
same time what explains with this
confidence and this transparency the unity
of the 27
we work in the same spirit
obviously with the European parliament
there are several subjects I explained
this to the European councils which made
the  object of real good progress and on
which we see much
more besides than a prospect of agreement
we are on the point of being able to
write  r clarified this agreement there is a
set of subjects on which there remain
not only
question marks and points of
divergence and then there are three subjects
on which the gap is too great
today for me to say
now  when I speak that the
perspective is that of a deal we
must modify its perspectives to
move towards a deal and for that we must
progress this is the case of the level playing
field this
is the case of governance and that  is
indeed also the case with
the fishing file so a lot of work a
lot of work which will
mobilize us damages regrets with
my counterpart david frost and then on Monday
we will be in london for the week
if necessary the weekend the
following week in brussels in any case what
i proposed to the british team
that files intensively in the
short time that we have left
to reach around the end
of october the agreement that we do
not wish to  any price but
there agree that we wish and that the
European leaders
obviously wish like ourselves
thank you for your attention five thousand
barrels [Music] barrels on the first question it is
certain that we must adapt
in the case of that  quickly 19 trade fairs for
which for each of the foolish trades
plans we consult widely with the
delegations and we take into
consideration the situation you know
that when the tribe that empty was
triggered for several months
we held meetings only
in a virtual way we noted  for
some topics, the physical presence
was essential to be able
to take the decision to make
hackers this is what happened in
July it is certain that we
also take into account the nature of the topics which
are under debate  the debate on the slowest
today does not actually require
a physical presence and many
leaders are finally expressed in  s this
physical presence for the future we will
systematically appreciate taking into
account the different parameters by
also consulting deviations
what are the best ways of
working given this crisis
that quickly concerns
everyone and also the institutions  the
European institutions
I tell you I confirm that
we are available as
we have always been we will remain
available until the last useful day
to give through this negotiation
which is not finished all its chances of
succeeding to obtain an agreement  so i
made this proposal today i
confirmed this availability i will tell
davy de fauw tomorrow that we are
ready to get to work
intensively accelerated as much
as possible in the coming days
from monday and  for the remaining two or three
weeks ahead of us five and
an exclusion
if tim carries everything and kin two
consideration at the po  lar concludes I don't
know the daughter of the two but it
may be 800 he swings but this
choice eric liao determines everything negotiate
killed said i'm into you dream on note
winners and ederson defense
defective men stop x 10 km from
bristol cards a bone at the bottom of level playing
field of advanced anouilh said ok i can't
end the ppt and yao views witch
is demonstrative unity and which
also slides back from m we win tin tin tin
data from these young people from bézy of the  end
of the great and the whip it it
tweets rust michel barnier twitts
west is we offer ging of transparency
between us métro de tristes between
also those of best
hall concluded a series of two games
in a row felt it swayed but went
played to icloud and men a
left tour and you said i'm into you eat
your dreams of ederson's twinner saturday's defense
are in the top 10
whether it's sheets that stood at the soffin
of level playing field of advanced and
we are told there ok I don't  respect and
chain of youth which is the most wanted
at unity and which dissociates
match nights from being we win tin all 30 years two
babies this old men of the three leaks
uefa
wikikit of west twitts michel barnier
of west twitts risk or and  of working
of transparency between us by toro rosso
where is this final
discussion period but for the moment we are
going to work intensively from
Monday with our teams in london on
fishing
, which I have observed by listening to the
heads of state  government that are
expressed is a great unity and
great solidarity that has always been there
among the 27 with the eleven countries concerned by
fishing activities and in particular
eight countries whose activity
largely depends on the quotas
that have been allocated to them in  British waters
I indicated as early as July an
opening to discuss I did not
really have any reciprocal opening
we know very well that we are going to have to
make an effort
there  this effort must be reasonable
it preserves the fishing activities of the
fishing companies of the
european union the united kingdom must understand
this to me that means a sustainable perspective
with this agreement it requires reciprocal access
to waters is  stable
the British moreover fish for
a significant part in the waters
which will be European waters the
day after the bric site
and then a distribution of the quotas which
is fair we are not there and I was a
little more specific by putting  at the
same time what we are asking the
British for access to their zoo
for our fishing companies and the
men and women who work there
and who do one of
the most difficult and dangerous jobs in
our societies and who participate in the
europe's food sovereignty a
parallel between what we are fairly asking for
as access to uk waters
for our
fishing businesses is what the brits  anniques we are
asking at the same time in many
many areas such as
easier open access to our markets for their
business
I gave the example of the
British requests for dax and for
the electrical interconnection of the single market
these are considerable sums which
are  at stake as large sums
are at stake with fishing
I could multiply the examples so
I have tried to put in parallel them
the opening of British waters to our
fishing companies and in a
proportionate and reciprocal way the opening
of important sectors  of the single
European market to British companies and
you can clearly see that we have to be able to
explain at the end of these negotiations
that we treat in the same way
with the same respect and openness our
fishing companies in British waters
and the companies
British in our home
market anyway in some
market sectors thank you
[Music]
a recovery takes  Of course, as
part of our little transparency,
I would be happy to give you
all the details, but we are in the
middle of negotiations
and, as I told you, as I
want to confirm, we are not at the end of
this negotiation on this subject.  like on a
few others, but the level playing
field has always been at the heart it's
a bit of a techno word I recognize that I
prefer to say economic fair play of the
rules of the game in a way
what do the European countries which
are  ready to open their markets
under absolutely unprecedented conditions
we have never offered any
third country a trade opening 0 tariff
zero quotas at the start of a negotiation
we simply wish that the
regulatory and
legislative sovereignty that the united kingdom
regains 100%  next January 1st
cannot be used
as a tool of dumping against European
companies and economic sectors
and this is a so  uci legitimate
because it is the first time in
European commercial history for
50 or 60 years that we are negotiating with a
third country in trade agreements in
a context of regulatory divergence
and not regulatory convergence
we are today aligned  the
british are leaving the european union
and the single market leaving the
european union on february 1st they are leaving the
single market on december 31st and they
want to diverge that's even one of the
reasons for the break site they want to be
free to diverge the question that we
let's ask knows if there should be
tariff-free and quota-free access to our market
of 450 million consumers 22
million companies is
this difference are reasonable and
will it be controlled by whom within
the kingdom  united is that we will be able to
be informed transparency is very
important and therefore we have the idea of
ing to test in the treaty fairl
precise principles of avoi  r
assurances of domestic force min
with authorities on each side to have a
toolbox of disputes it is
so effective and perhaps also to be
able to take unilateral measures
when there are reciprocal disputes on both sides
we are
working on these ideas but I
will not say more we have a
lot of work on this subject as
on a few others we will remain
until the end very respectful very
calm and in particular respect
British sovereignty
sometimes i hear this debate i
know of course sovereignty there is
no question the uk becomes
is a fully sovereign country and we
respect that as it has to respect
our own autonomy
i think between two parties in the
kingdom  united the european union who have
this autonomy who have
sovereignty funds in a respectful way
build a framework of transparency of the
exchange of c  consistency of
regulatory equivalence so that the competition
is free and fair fer unsri this
is what is at stake in the negotiation a
point on this subject the member states of
the european union
naturally recognize the right of the
British authorities to choose whether it  it is their
desire to diverge from
European standards in terms of
environmental and social terms, for
example, but from the moment that this is
the choice that is necessarily made
there are consequences for access to
the internal market  is that the challenge of
fair play and tonic and that is the challenge
of the discussions that are in progress to
try to see in such a way we can
release actors it is our wish to
release a capacity to maintain a
close future relationship  in the process of
mutual trust borrowing
cooperation the ability to work
together in many areas
class it is believed that there is a mutual interest
but when there is this important
issue  we that you are British who is
this hope of this choice to be able to
diverge from European standards
everyone understands it is a question of
common sense that there are necessarily
consequences in connection with the axis they
hope for the market  interior
for dei unit planned
you enter the european union and the
united kingdom in brick city or united and
determined to which would have to be
based on brings